A friend in South Africa sent me the link to this article that is making the rounds there. It's an open letter, supposedly from the foreign media, to every man, woman, and child in their country.
我在南非的一位朋友给我发来了这篇文章的链接，这篇文章正在当地广为流传。这是一封公开信，据说是由外国媒体写给该国每一位男人、女人和孩子的。
It begins, "Dear South Africa, please get the F of the way. Wait, that probably came out wrong. As you may have noted, we're back!" Meaning of course, that the foreign press has returned to South Africa to cover what is happening now with Nelson Mandela. I'll go back to the letter.
开头是这样的：“亲爱的南非，请滚开。等等，这话说得可能不对。正如你们可能注意到的，我们回来了！”当然，这意味着外国媒体已经回到南非，报道纳尔逊·曼德拉目前的情况。我回到信的内容。
"In the real world, far away from your sleepy backwater, news works on a 24-hour cycle, and you need to get out of the way. It's nothing personal. In fact, we couldn't do this successfully without you.
“在现实世界中，远离你们那昏昏欲睡的偏远地区，新闻是以24小时为周期运作的，你们需要让开。这没什么个人恩怨。事实上，没有你们，我们无法成功做到这一点。
In many cases, our footage is made more compelling by your presence. Specifically, we are fond of small black children praying and slash or singing in unison. Equally telegenic are the Aryan ubermensch blond kids, also praying slash singing, who help underscore the theme that Mandela united people of all races under a rainbow umbrella.
在许多情况下，你们的存在使我们的镜头更具感染力。具体来说，我们喜欢那些祈祷和/或齐声歌唱的黑人小孩。同样上镜的还有雅利安超人式的金发小孩，他们也在祈祷/歌唱，这有助于强调曼德拉在彩虹伞下团结了所有种族人民的主题。
Also very important, thematically speaking, are Mandela's successors. We very much like the idea that your ex-president was quote, 'one of a kind', and that despite his best efforts, the current batch of idiots proved that he was an exceptional presence. Sui generis. And we don't have to worry about someone else like him coming along in Africa ever again.
此外，从主题上讲，非常重要的是曼德拉的继任者们。我们非常喜欢这样的观点：你们的前总统是‘独一无二的’，尽管他尽了最大努力，但目前这批白痴证明了他是一个非凡的存在。独一无二。我们再也不用担心非洲会再出现像他这样的人了。
We enjoy your leaders' bumbling ways, their daft nonsequiturs. This story would lack a tragic arc without Jacob Zuma." That of course, is the current president of the country. "May he keep on keeping on."
我们喜欢你们领导人笨拙的方式，他们愚蠢的离题话。没有雅各布·祖马，这个故事将缺少一个悲剧性的弧线。”当然，这就是该国现任总统。“愿他继续保持下去。”
The letter continues. "Then there's the Mandela family. Really, where would we derive our soap operatic undertones if it weren't for the infighting and blinged-up brashness of that clan? We love subtly implying that a saint sired a generation of professional shoppers, no-goodniks.
信中继续写道。“还有曼德拉家族。真的，如果不是因为那个家族的内斗和浮华的炫耀，我们从哪里获得肥皂剧般的底蕴呢？我们喜欢含蓄地暗示，一位圣人竟然生出了这一代只会购物的专业人士和无赖。”
In our biz we call that irony. Makes for great copy. In fact, we love everything about the country that doesn't live up to Mandela's legacy.
在我们的行业里，我们称之为讽刺。这能写出很棒的稿子。事实上，我们喜欢这个国家所有不符合曼德拉遗产的一切。
We will take every opportunity to mention how everything you do flies in the face of everything Mandela would have wanted for his people, how you're basically a nation of underachieving screw ups. All of this is fantastic. We thank you profusely for your individual and collective contributions to this essential storyline, and urge you to keep squandering your potential."
我们将抓住每一个机会提到，你们所做的一切是如何违背曼德拉为他的人民所希望的一切，你们基本上是一个缺乏成就、搞砸一切的国家。所有这些都太棒了。我们衷心感谢你们为这一重要故事情节所做出的个人和集体贡献，并敦促你们继续挥霍你们的潜力。”
Can I say what I love about this? It was written by a journalist named Richard Poplak for the South African news service Daily Maverick, which you can find online.
我能说说我喜欢它的原因吗？它是由一位名叫理查德·波普拉克（Richard Poplak）的记者为南非新闻服务机构“每日小牛”（Daily Maverick）撰写的，你可以在网上找到。
What I love about this is how it doesn't just take us foreigners inside how a South African might see our news coverage and the tone of that coverage, it also reveals a world of utterly justified resentments that I guess maybe we could have suspected, but we didn't really know about. It is an insider's view totally.
我喜欢这篇文章的原因在于，它不仅让我们这些外国人深入了解了南非人如何看待我们的新闻报道以及报道的基调，它还揭示了一个完全合理的怨恨世界，我想也许我们早就怀疑过，但并没有真正了解。这是一个完全内部人的视角。
Well, today on our radio show, we have stories from three radically different locations. We dive into three very different worlds for the insider's view that only insiders have.
今天在我们的广播节目中，我们有来自三个截然不同地点的故事。我们深入研究三个非常不同的世界，获取只有内部人士才有的内部视角。
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life, distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
这里是来自芝加哥WBEZ的《美国生活》（This American Life），由国际公共广播电台（Public Radio International）发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。请继续收听。
Act One, The Weeds of Discontent. What we have now is a recording of a very unusual conversation that came about in an unusual way.
第一幕，不满的杂草。我们现在听到的是一段非常不寻常的谈话录音，这段谈话的由来也非同寻常。
There's this filmmaker named Eugene Jarecki who made a documentary about prisons and the criminal justice system called The House I Live In . And he's been taking it around the country and showing it in prisons, kind of Johnny Cash style, for inmates and corrections staff.
有一位名叫尤金·贾瑞奇（Eugene Jarecki）的电影制作人，他拍摄了一部关于监狱和刑事司法系统的纪录片，名为《我居住的房子》（The House I Live In）。他带着这部片子在全国各地巡回，像强尼·卡什（Johnny Cash）那样，在监狱里为囚犯和矫正工作人员放映。
One of our producers, Brian Reed, went to one of those screenings, which is where this conversation happened. Here's Brian.
我们的制片人之一布莱恩·里德（Brian Reed）参加了其中一场放映会，这段对话就是在那儿发生的。下面请听布莱恩的报道。
The screening I saw was at Joseph Harp Correctional Center, a medium security prison in Lexington, Oklahoma. About 35 inmates, most of them in for drug related crimes or with a history of drug use, sat waiting in the visiting room in chairs facing a projector screen.
我看到的放映会是在俄克拉何马州莱克星顿的一所中度安全监狱——约瑟夫·哈普惩教中心（Joseph Harp Correctional Center）举行的。大约35名囚犯，大多数是因为毒品相关犯罪入狱或有吸毒史，坐在探视室的椅子上，面对着投影屏幕。
Once we get to where we're getting ready to start the movie, if you're here, you're staying.
一旦我们准备开始放映电影，既然你来了，你就得留下来。
More than a dozen staff members came to watch the movie too, including the warden and some state officials from the Oklahoma Department of Corrections. And before the screening started, what did these drug offenders think the movie was going to be about?
十几名工作人员也来看了这部电影，包括监狱长和来自俄克拉何马州惩教署的一些州官员。在放映开始前，这些毒品罪犯认为这部电影是关于什么的呢？
Rehab.
戒毒。
Probably about some drugs and how to prevent yourself from doing some drugs.
可能是关于一些毒品，以及如何预防自己不接触毒品。
How drugs is bad for you. How it mess up your skin and your body. Make you age quicker too.
毒品对你有多坏。它是如何破坏你的皮肤和身体的。还会让你老得更快。
But these guys were way off base. The House I Live In is about how drugs are bad for them, but not in the way they were expecting.
但这些人完全猜错了。《我居住的房子》确实是关于毒品对他们有多么不好，但并不是他们预期的那种方式。
Because it argues that the war on drugs has completely failed. That it's made law enforcement less effective and overwhelmed prisons. That's it's a self-perpetuating system which preys on poor, uneducated people. A system where politicians win elections by being tough on crime, a multi-billion dollar industry and entire towns thrive off the business of incarceration, and laws trap people with few opportunities in a cycle of committing crimes.
因为它论证了禁毒战争已经彻底失败。它使执法效率降低，并让监狱不堪重负。这是一个自我延续的系统，它掠夺贫穷、未受教育的人。一个政客通过对犯罪强硬来赢得选举的系统，一个价值数十亿美元的产业，整个城镇依靠监禁产业为生，而法律则将几乎没有机会的人困在犯罪的循环中。
People don't realize, for example, that when you arrest a young black man and he goes to jail, when he gets out of the prison, he can't get a job in most places because of his record.
例如，人们没有意识到，当你逮捕一个年轻的黑人男子，他进了监狱，当他出狱时，因为他的犯罪记录，他在大多数地方都找不到工作。
This is Charles Ogletree, a professor at Harvard Law School.
这是查尔斯·奥格尔特里（Charles Ogletree），哈佛法学院教授。
If he wants to go back to school to go to college, he's ineligible by law for certain grants. He can't get certain health care benefits. His family that was the centerpiece of his life, if they're living in public housing, they can't take him in. He can't vote!
如果他想回学校上大学，他依法没有资格获得某些助学金。他无法获得某些医疗保健福利。作为他生活核心的家人，如果他们住在公共住房里，他们不能收留他。他不能投票！
The film has interviews with people throughout the criminal justice system. Inmates and their families, but also judges, police officers, and prison staff. Almost all of them say, in some way or another, that the system needs to be fixed.
这部电影采访了整个刑事司法系统中的人们。包括囚犯和他们的家人，但也包括法官、警察和监狱工作人员。几乎所有人都以这样或那样的方式表示，这个系统需要修复。
And what made it even more interesting for this audience in Oklahoma is that several people from the Oklahoma Department of Corrections are in the movie. And a couple of them were at the screening, watching it with the prisoners. Like Mike Carpenter, who oversees security for Oklahoma's medium security prisons.
对俄克拉何马州的观众来说，更让他们感兴趣的是，俄克拉何马州惩教署的几个人就在电影里。其中几个人就在放映现场，和囚犯们一起观看。比如负责俄克拉何马州中度安全监狱安保工作的迈克·卡彭特（Mike Carpenter）。
I am very much a law and order kind of guy. I would rather have 10 police cars than 1 soup kitchen if you give me the choice. But sometimes I think that we need to be smarter about what those police officers are actually out there doing.
我是一个非常崇尚法律和秩序的人。如果让我选择，我宁愿有10辆警车，也不要一个救济食堂。但有时我认为，我们需要对那些警察实际在做什么更加聪明一点。
I think sometimes we have people doing a whole lot of time for not very much crime. It's almost like they're paying for our fear, instead of paying for their crime.
我想有时人们因为并不严重的犯罪而服刑很久。这简直就像他们在为我们的恐惧买单，而不是为他们的罪行买单。
So when the screening was over, some of the inmates were surprised that prison staff had even shown them this at all. One guy said it was exhilarating to hear corrections officers say things like, "We're jailing too many people. We're locking them up for too long."
所以当放映结束时，一些囚犯很惊讶监狱工作人员竟然会给他们看这个。一个人说，听到矫正官说出“我们关押的人太多了。我们把他们关得太久了”这样的话，真是令人振奋。
So we had this idea. We thought the film might prompt a conversation that prisoners and guards don't normally get to have about the prison system. And Oklahoma corrections authorities agreed to give us a room where I could sit down prisoners and guards and they could talk to each other one on one.
所以我们有了这个主意。我们认为这部电影可能会促成一场囚犯和狱警通常无法进行的关于监狱系统的对话。俄克拉何马州惩教当局同意给我们一个房间，让我可以让囚犯和狱警坐下来一对一地谈话。
Who do you want to talk to? Who do you want to talk with?
你想和谁谈？你想和谁交流？
I want to talk to Dooley and Shelock.
我想和杜利（Dooley）和谢洛克（Shelock）谈。
OK. Why do you want to talk to them?
好的。你为什么想和他们谈？
My own personal opinions.
我个人的看法。
This is Antwaun Wells. He's 25, serving the third year of a nine year sentence for shooting a guy during an argument and also for stealing TVs from a Target and then stabbing a security guard in the arm on the way out of the store.
这是安特万·威尔斯（Antwaun Wells）。他25岁，正在服九年刑期的第三年，罪名是在争执中射伤了一个人，还在从塔吉特（Target）百货商店出来时偷了电视机，并刺伤了一名保安的手臂。
It's not his first time in prison. He'd been in before. One of the staff members he picked-- Shelock-- wasn't around. But Dooley was.
这不是他第一次进监狱。他之前进去过。他选的工作人员之一——谢洛克——不在。但杜利在。
Dooley is Lt. Cecil Dooley. He's been a corrections officer for 14 years. He's a big burly guy. He wasn't there to see the movie. He was the guard on duty supervising the inmates as they watched the film.
杜利是塞西尔·杜利中尉（Lt. Cecil Dooley）。他当矫正官已经14年了。他是个身材魁梧的家伙。他不是来看电影的。他是当班的守卫，负责监督囚犯看电影。
I recorded other conversations throughout the day. But this was the one that stood out.
我在这一天录制了其他对话。但这一个是表现最突出的。
We're going to go in here. Pardon me, guys. We got our first pair. We'll see how this goes.
我们要进去这里。抱歉，伙计们。我们有了第一对。看看进展如何。
Lt. Dooley and Antwaun sat down facing each other. I sat off to the side to try and stay out of their way.
杜利中尉和安特万面对面坐着。我坐在旁边，尽量不碍他们的事。
Now let me say here that this whole thing was a total experiment. I don't think any of us knew what to expect. And just to get in front of this, Antwaun did not bring Dooley in here to talk about the movie.
现在让我说，这一切完全是一个实验。我想我们都没人知道会发生什么。为了先发制人，安特万找杜利进来不是为了谈电影。
All right, so you wanted to bring him in here and ask him a question.
好的，所以你想把他叫进来问他一个问题。
Yep.
是的。
Do you have your question?
你有你的问题了吗？
I want to know why y'all feel that it's so important for y'all to demand respect, but don't want to give it.
我想知道为什么你们觉得要求得到尊重那么重要，却不想给予别人尊重。
When you say "y'all," you putting everybody in the same boat.
当你把“你们”放在一起说时，你是把所有人都归为一类了。
Well, I can't put everyone in the same boat, because there is some guards that are respectful. But it's some-- being you in particular with me-- I feel that you're just disrespectful.
嗯，我不能把每个人都归为一类，因为确实有一些狱警是尊重的。但有一些——特别是你对我——我觉得你只是不尊重人。
Like the other day in the office, I asked you to come here. If you was to ask me to come here and I told you to hold on, you'd have wrote me up because I didn't follow a direct order.
就像前几天在办公室，我让你来这里。如果你让我来这里，而我说等一下，你就会写报告举报我，因为我没有遵循直接命令。
I acknowledged you. I told you to hold on.
我回应你了。我让你等一下。
I [INAUDIBLE].
我[听不清]。
Unless you're bleeding, dying, or giving birth, the stuff that I had going on was much more important than what you needed at that time.
除非你在流血、垂死或正在分娩，否则我手头的事比你当时需要的要重要得多。
I just feel--
我只是觉得——
I've never once called you outside of your name.
我从来没有叫过你的名字之外的称呼。
No, that's--
不，那是——
I've never slandered you in any way.
我从来没有以任何方式诽谤过你。
Yeah. No. And I'm not gonna say that and I never will say that incident happened. But what I'm saying is that's not the only--
是的。不。我不会说那个，我永远也不会说那个事件发生了。但我想说的是那不是唯一——
But you come in here and you say I was disrespectful because you don't get what you want when you want it.
但你走进来，说我不尊重人，因为你没能在想要的时候得到你想要的。
In my eyes, I feel like you and other guards view us as if we're nothing. Y'all walk round with y'all head held up. You know what I'm saying?
在我眼里，我觉得你和其他守卫把我们视为无物。你们走来走去，昂着头。你明白我的意思吗？
It's always, y'all win. No matter what the situation is, y'all win. You have a arrogant attitude. Your attitude is I'm Dooley. I'm big bad Dooley.
总是你们赢。无论情况如何，都是你们赢。你有一种傲慢的态度。你的态度就是“我是杜利”。我是那个厉害的大块头杜利。
If I tell you to do something that's not illegal, that's not going to jeopardize your life, that's not offensive, you should have no problem doing it. Whether you like it or not is a totally different story.
如果我让你做某件不违法、不会危及生命、也不冒犯人的事，你应该没有问题去执行。不管你喜不喜欢，那是完全不同的故事。
That's where the disrespect come in. Because you had--
那才是不尊重人的地方。因为你曾——
That's not disrespectful.
那不叫不尊重人。
OK, you had me pick up dandelions.
好的，你让我捡蒲公英。
Yes.
是的。
Just to prove a point to me. To prove a point that y'all have power.
只是为了向我证明一个观点。为了证明你们拥有权力的观点。
OK. So you're still upset over the dandelion deal?
好的。所以你还在为蒲公英的事生气？
Yes, I really am. That really actually frustrated me.
是的，我确实很生气。那确实让我很沮丧。
If you wouldn't have bucked up against that officer that day--
如果你那天没有跟那个官员作对——
But see, that's what I'm saying. You never came and asked me exactly what happened.
但你看，这就是我要说的。你从来没有来问我到底发生了什么。
Don't need to.
不需要。
Exactly. You took your officer's word and you left it at that. It's always three sides to each story. My side, his side, and the truth.
正是。你听信了你属下的话，就这样结束了。每个故事都有三个方面。我的方面，他的方面，还有真相。
You left two sides out and you went off of what your officer said. You never came to me as a man and asked me. You know what I'm saying?
你忽略了两个方面，完全根据你属下说的话行事。你从来没有像个男人一样来问我。你明白我的意思吗？
I did.
我问过。
And then you forced me to do something just because you could. And if I didn't, you threatened to ship me.
然后你强迫我做某事仅仅因为你能。如果我不做，你威胁要把我转走。
Antwaun is saying Lt. Dooley threatened to ship him to another prison.
安特万是说杜利中尉威胁要把他转到另一所监狱。
I don't remember threatening to ship you. But I could.
我不记得威胁要转走你。但我可以。
Yes, you threatened to ship me.
是的，你威胁要转走我。
I could. Disobedience to order.
我可以。抗命。
Exactly. And you told me trying to override your staff, you could ship me.
正是。你告诉我，试图越过你的员工，你就可以转走我。
Mm hmm. I could.
嗯嗯。我可以。
And if I didn't pick up dandelions,  you'll put me in a holding cell.
如果我不捡蒲公英，你就会把我关进牢房。
And if I remember correctly, that was over you trying to get other people to stand up against that officer and not do what he was telling you to do.
如果我没记错的话，那是因为你试图让其他人站出来反抗那个官员，不要做他告诉你们做的事情。
No. That's exactly what I'm  saying.
不。那正是我想说的。
So OK, sure. They weren't talking about the history of the drug war or the prison industrial complex or any of the other big ideas from the movie.
好的，没问题。他们没有谈论禁毒战争的历史、监狱工业复合体或电影中任何其他宏大的想法。
But it was interesting to listen to them argue like this. It was intimate. It was personal. They were bickering like family members. Like a dad and his kid going at it.
但听他们这样争论很有意思。这是亲密的。这是私人的。他们像家庭成员一样争吵。就像父亲和孩子在争执。
And I felt like I was seeing something people on the outside don't usually have the opportunity to see. You realize, oh, right, these two are embedded in each other's lives in a way that only happens when one person has the power to punish the other and the other person has a whole lot of time to stew over it.
我觉得我看到了外界人们通常没有机会看到的东西。你意识到，哦，对了，这两个人以一种只有在一个人有权力惩罚另一个人，而另一个人有大量时间去为之烦恼时才会发生的方式，嵌入了彼此的生活。
And the thing that was bugging Antwaun, the dandelions, seems small, but kind of gets to the heart of what he hates about being incarcerated. And he wanted to hash that out with Dooley.
而困扰安特万的那件事——蒲公英，看起来很小，但触及了他讨厌被监禁的核心。他想和杜利把这件事理清楚。
Obviously, there's disagreement about what happened that day, which was months ago, by the way. Antwaun says another officer had given some other inmates a few tasks to do, like pick up trash. Antwaun went up to the other inmates and told them they were allowed to do the tasks in a different order than the guard did.
显然，对于那天发生的事情，也就是几个月前的事，存在分歧。安特万说另一名官员给其他囚犯布置了一些任务，比如捡垃圾。安特万走到其他囚犯那里，告诉他们可以按不同于守卫的顺序完成任务。
Dooley says that's not how it happened. That Antwaun Wells was telling other inmates to disobey a guard. So Dooley gave him what they call extra duty. In this case, to pick dandelions.
杜利说事情不是这样发生的。安特万·威尔斯当时在教唆其他囚犯违抗守卫。所以杜利给了他所谓的额外任务。在这种情况下，就是捡蒲公英。
I don't--
我不——
Was it hard?
很难吗？
No. I mean, it wasn't hard. It was just--
不。我是说，那并不难。只是——
Did it take a lot of time?
花了很多时间吗？
No. It didn't take a lot of time. It's still the principle. You made me--
不。并没有花很多时间。这仍然是原则问题。你强迫我——
Did you break any bones?
你骨折了吗？
No. You could have said, go pick up some trash. You specifically made me pick up a flower that grows out the ground.
没有。你可以说，去捡些垃圾。你特别让我去捡地上长的花。
Mm hmm.
嗯嗯。
Just because you could.
仅仅因为你能。
Right.
对。
Exactly. It's always going to be officers that feel like just because I have the power and authority, I can do and say what I want to to these people.
正是。总是会有官员觉得仅仅因为我有权力和权威，我就可以对这些人做我想做的事，说我想说的话。
There wasn't just to put power and authority. I am where I am because I have morals, ethics, and beliefs that I stand by.
那不仅仅是为了行使权力和权威。我之所以在现在的位置，是因为我有我所坚持的道德、伦理和信念。
Still yet even once again--
即便如此，再一次——
I think your problem, Mr. Wells, is you like to dwell on the fact that you don't get your way each and every time. And that's part of the reason that you're in prison--
我想你的问题是，威尔斯先生，你喜欢纠结于你并没有每次都如愿以偿的事实。这也是你入狱的部分原因——
No, it's not.
不，不是的。
--is because you like to buck the system.
——是因为你喜欢反抗体制。
I'm in prison 'cause I shot somebody. I'll never deny that fact.
我入狱是因为我射伤了人。我永远不会否认这个事实。
OK.
好的。
I'm in prison because I put myself here.
我入狱是因为我把自己送进来的。
OK.
好的。
I made the choices in my life because I chose to.
我做出生活中的选择是因为我选择了这么做。
And those are poor decisions.
而那些是糟糕的决定。
I don't blame nobody for nothing that happens. But when I feel that's just like there's some guards here that's just rude for no reason. I don't understand that.
我不责怪任何人发生的事情。但是当我感觉到这里有一些守卫毫无理由地粗鲁时。我不明白这一点。
You didn't care enough about me to even ask me my opinion. You didn't care enough about nothing that I had going on, once again, because I'm an inmate. Y'all feel just because I came to the penitentiary, that I have no rights.
你根本不在乎我，连问我的意见都不问。你根本不在乎我正在经历什么，再一次，因为我是一名囚犯。你们觉得仅仅因为我进了监狱，我就没有权利。
You being an offender has nothing to do with it. 'Cause you have no say over anything.
你是罪犯与此无关。因为你对任何事情都没有发言权。
Policy and procedure.
政策和程序。
You have no say to tell my officer what he can and cannot do, to ask people to do.
你没有发言权去告诉我的官员他可以做什么，不可以做什么，去要求别人做什么。
Exactly. That's the point where you're missing. I told the inmates that. I didn't tell the officer nothing.
正是。这就是你忽略的地方。我告诉囚犯们了。我没对那个官员说什么。
Right. Which makes you the person that was instigating.
对。这让你成了挑起事端的人。
They went on like this for more than 20 minutes.
他们就这样谈了20多分钟。
I know you don't like me, just like I don't like you.
我知道你不喜欢我，就像我不喜欢你一样。
I've never disrespected you and my job has nothing to do with like or dislike.
我从来没有不尊重你，我的工作与喜欢或不喜欢无关。
You disrespected me that day that you didn't ask me my side of the story and you made me pick up dandelions--
你那天不听我的辩解，强迫我捡蒲公英，你就是不尊重我——
That's not disrespect.
那不叫不尊重。
Because you could.
因为你能。
That's not disrespect.
那不叫不尊重。
You power abused because you could. You just admitted it.
你滥用权力，因为你能。你刚刚承认了。
It's not even abuse of power.
那甚至不是滥用权力。
OK.
好的。
Finally I interrupted and asked them what they thought about the movie we just watched. Dooley had actually seen it before. He had it recorded on his DVR. And he liked it.
最后我插话问他们对我们刚看的电影有什么看法。杜利实际上之前看过。他录在DVR里了。他很喜欢。
He told me that for several years now, he's felt that the country needs to rethink the way it does corrections. He said he often tells inmates that when they get down to the last three years or so of their sentence, he thinks they should be released early.
他告诉我，几年来他一直觉得国家需要重新思考矫正方式。他说他经常告诉囚犯，当他们服刑只剩下最后三年左右时，他认为他们应该提前获释。
When you see that movie and when you think about your day to day, are you dissatisfied? Are you frustrated with the system, where it's gotten?
当你看到那部电影，当你想到你的日常生活时，你感到不满吗？你对这个系统、对它所达到的地步感到沮丧吗？
Absolutely. Absolutely.
绝对，绝对。
What frustrates you most?
什么最让你沮丧？
The fact that we have now taken people and made them a monetary commodity. Right now the big thing is the push to privatization. To make money off of prisons, to make money off of people's lives, to make money to incarcerate people. That to me, seems backwards.
事实是我们现在已经把人变成了货币商品。现在最大的是推动私有化。从监狱中赚钱，从人们的生活中赚钱，从监禁人们中赚钱。这对我来说似乎是倒退的。
He turned to Antwaun for a second.
他转向安特万一下。
And this is not to push your button or anything like that. I did more in 10 seconds of his life by making him pick up dandelions. He will remember the fact that I came up there and I told him to pick dandelions for arguing with an officer. He will remember that forever.
这不是为了刺激你什么的。我用那10秒钟让他捡蒲公英，对他的人生产生的影响更多。他会记得我走到那里告诉他因为和官员争吵而捡蒲公英的事实。他会永远记得。
And if that one issue makes him hate me to the point where he doesn't ever want to put himself in that position again, then I have done my job. I've done my job to correct an action forever.
如果这一个问题让他恨我到他再也不想把自己置于那种境地，那么我就完成了我的工作。我完成了纠正一个行为的工作，永远地。
What do you think of that, Antwaun? You get that?
安特万，你怎么看？你明白吗？
I mean, I understand it. But I still don't feel that it's fair.
我是说，我理解。但我仍然觉得那不公平。
Penitentiary to me is just slavery in another form. In my eyes, these is my owners and I have to do what they say, otherwise I have consequences. Just like the slave master. You either do what he say or you get punished.
对我来说，监狱只是另一种形式的奴隶制。在我眼里，这些人是我的主人，我必须做他们说的，否则我会有后果。就像奴隶主。你要么做他说的，要么你就会受到惩罚。
Then the conversation got more personal. Lt. Dooley told Antwaun that the last time he got out of prison he had a chance to stay out, to make a different life for himself. But instead he re-offended.
然后对话变得更加私密。杜利中尉告诉安特万，他上次出狱时有机会留在外面，过上不同的生活。但他反而再次犯案。
Antwaun said he didn't have many options. And it was around this point that Antwaun and Dooley actually started to hear each other out a bit.
安特万说他没有太多选择。就是在这一点上，安特万和杜利实际上开始听取对方的一点意见了。
What was I supposed to do? I come from the hood. I come from nothing. You tell me, what was I supposed to do?
我能做什么？我来自贫民区。我一无所有。你告诉我，我能做什么？
Now you're talking outside my purview, because I don't know where you're from.
现在你说的超出了我的职权范围，因为我不知道你是哪里人。
Exactly. Exactly. You don't know where I'm from. And I don't feel that you would care.
正是。正是。你不知道我是哪里人。而且我觉得你也不会在乎。
Me as a person, if I didn't have all the tattoos or whatever, if I had the money to get them removed, you could put me in a white collar neighborhood and I could make it because I have a education. You know what I'm saying? I have two years of college.
作为我个人，如果我没有所有的纹身什么的，如果有钱把它们去掉，你可以把我放在白领社区，我能成功，因为我有教育。你明白我的意思吗？我有两年的大学学历。
I have no other option but to accept my choices I made. You know what I'm saying? I do admit my failures. You know what  I'm saying?
除了接受我所做的选择，我别无选择。你明白我的意思吗？我确实承认我的失败。你明白我的意思吗？
But I will say that there were obstacles that at that time, I didn't think right of overcoming, so I chose the wrong way to overcome them.
但我会说，当时有一些我没认为有权克服的障碍，所以我选择了错误的克服方式。
You know what? I grew up very poor. I didn't know I was poor. My mom always had two different jobs growing up. I was taking care of my little brother at the age of eight by myself.
你知道吗？我在非常贫穷中长大。我不知道我很穷。我妈妈在成长过程中总是做两份不同的工作。我八岁的时候就在独自照顾我弟弟。
I'm on this side, you're on that side. That's all decisions. And you know the difference between right and wrong.
我在这边，你在那边。那都是决定。而且你知道对和错的区别。
Yeah.
是的。
But you make the conscious decision to continue doing the same things and expect different results.
但你做出了有意识的决定，继续做同样的事情，并期望得到不同的结果。
Sometimes you get pinned in a corner and you're forced to do what you know. Like when I got out of the penitentiary this time, for three days I wore the same clothes until I went out and had to steal me some clothes. My sister and my brother and my mama didn't give me no handout. You know what I'm saying?
有时你会被逼到墙角，被迫做你知道的事情。就像我这次出狱时，三天我都穿着同样的衣服，直到我不得不出去偷些衣服。我姐姐、我弟弟和我妈妈没给我任何帮助。你明白我的意思吗？
Jobs, they won't-- you're a felon. You know what I'm saying? I applied for 35 jobs with my little brother. And just because both of us is felons, we got nowhere.
工作，他们不会——你是个重刑犯。你明白我的意思吗？我和我弟弟申请了35份工作。就因为我们俩都是重刑犯，我们无处可去。
So what am I gonna do? I'm going to go commit a crime, make me some money, and then go get me a dope sack.
所以我该怎么办？我打算去犯个罪，赚点钱，然后去买袋毒品。
See, if I were to go, the first thing I would do would try to go pick up a lawn mower or something and go mow some lawns. That's the difference in thought.
看，如果是我，我做的第一件事就是尝试去弄台割草机，去修剪草坪。这就是思想上的差异。
Yeah. That was an option. But still, yeah, once again, where am I gonna get the lawn mower from?
是的。那是种选择。但仍然，再一次，我从哪里弄割草机？
I got friends.
我有朋友。
I feel like society made a lot of rules to keep people safe. But at the same time, the people that they was trying to keep safe from, they gave us no other option but to go back out and re-offend because they put so many limitations on what we could do that where you have no other option but to go back to what you used to do.
我觉得社会为了保障人们安全制定了很多规则。但与此同时，那些他们试图保障人们安全的对象，却没给我们任何选择，只能再次出去再次犯罪，因为他们对我们能做的事情限制太多了，导致你别无选择，只能回到你曾经做的事情上去。
I've heard that same story for 14 years. I don't know how to fix it. If I did, I'd be a millionaire. If I did, there wouldn't be people in prison because I could tell them how to fix it.
这种故事我听了14年了。我不知道如何修复它。如果我知道，我就是百万富翁了。如果我知道，监狱里就不会有人了，因为我可以告诉他们如何修复它。
That conversation took place about a month and a half ago. And since then, I've wondered if it changed anything for Antwaun and Lt. Dooley, if it improved their relationship at all. So I called them up the other day to ask them.
那场对话发生在大约一个半月前。从那时起，我就想知道它是否给安特万和杜利中尉带来了一些变化，是否改善了他们的关系。所以前几天我给他们打了电话问问。
I talked to Dooley first and he said he'd only run into Antwaun a couple times since they'd talked. So he hadn't really noticed a difference.
我先和杜利谈了，他说自他们谈话后他只碰到过安特万几次。所以他真的没注意到什么不同。
But he did come down here. And when I called him down for this interview, he didn't have that same negative attitude he normally did.
但他确实到这里来了。当我为了这次采访把他叫来时，他没有通常那种消极的态度。
Dooley said he hadn't thought much about the conversation since it happened. And when I asked him if it changed him at all, if he felt more sympathetic towards Antwaun or if he thought differently now about the way he disciplines inmates, he said no. Not at all. Then he went to get Antwaun.
杜利说自对话发生后他没怎么想过。当我问他这是否改变了他一点，如果他现在对安特万感到更同情，或者他现在对惩戒囚犯的方式有不同看法时，他说没有。一点也没有。然后他去叫安特万。
Now hold on just a second.
现在等一下。
[PHONE RINGING]
[电话铃声]
Are you still there?
你还在吗？
I am.
在。
If you'll have a seat right there, Mr. Wells. This is the gentleman that did our interview while we were in the room when they came and showed the video. Here he is.
如果你坐在那里，威尔斯先生。这就是在我们房间里他们来播放视频时进行采访的那位先生。他在这儿。
Hello?
喂？
Hi, Antwaun?
嗨，安特万？
Yes.
是。
Hi, it's Brian Reed. How are you?
嗨，我是布莱恩·里德。你好吗？
I'm doing all right.
我还好。
I asked Antwaun the same question. Had the conversation changed anything between him and Dooley? And he said yeah, it had.
我问了安特万同样的问题。那场谈话改变了他和杜利之间的任何事情吗？他说是的，改变了。
Well, to me before it was like if I asked for something, he was dismissive or he'd keep going as if he didn't see me or something like that. But now if I ask him a question or whatever, he takes the time to talk to me about the issue right then and there. He doesn't blow me off. You know what I mean? I feel now that he looks at me as a human being more than he did then.
嗯，对我来说，之前就像是我问什么东西，他很轻蔑，或者他会继续走，就好像他没看到我之类的。但现在如果我问他问题什么的，他会当即花时间和我谈论这个问题。他不会敷衍我。你知道我的意思吗？我觉得他现在看我更像是一个人了，比那时候多。
Wow. It's interesting, 'cause I just got off the phone with Lt. Dooley, and he says the conversation hasn't changed him at all.
哇。很有意思，因为我刚和杜利中尉挂断电话，他说那场对话对他一点影响都没有。
To me it has. You know  what I'm saying? I don't know if it was the conversation or it was just that I didn't know him at the time. You know what I'm saying?
对我来说确实有。你知道我的意思吗？我不知道是因为那场谈话还是因为那时候我不认识他。你知道我的意思吗？
Or I didn't want to know him. I don't necessarily know. But I mean, I feel like the conversation that we had, I feel like it helped me even if it didn't help him. You know what I'm saying?
或者我不想认识他。我不一定知道。但我的意思是，我觉得我们进行的谈话，我觉得它帮助了我，即使它没有帮助他。你知道我的意思吗？
It maybe have helped me see him in, I don't know, I guess the way that he should be seen in. I'm not for sure. I just got to know that it's not him being disrespectful, it's just him doing his job. My perception was maybe the one that was off.
它也许帮助我看见他，我不知道，我想也许是以应该看待他的方式。我不确定。我只是必须知道那不是他不尊重人，那只是他在做他的工作。我的看法也许是错误的那个。
Wait, Antwaun. Is Lt. Dooley sitting right there?
等等，安特万。杜利中尉就在那里吗？
Nuh uh.
没有。
Really?
真的？
Yeah.
是的。
'Cause it's almost like you're totally proving him right. And I was wondering if he was watching over you right now to make sure you said these things.
因为这简直就像你完全证明他是对的。我很好奇他现在是否在看管着你以确保你说这些话。
Nuh uh. No.
没有。不。
It's surprising that this is where things ended up. When Antwaun went into the conversation, his goal was to bring Dooley around to seeing his side of things. Instead, the opposite happened.
令人惊讶的是事情最终变成了这样。当安特万进入那场对话时，他的目标是让杜利转而从他的角度看问题。相反，结果恰恰相反。
Brian Reed. You can see Eugene Jarecki's prison movie The House I Live In . And believe me, it will get to you. It's available on every possible internet platform-- iTunes, Netflix, Amazon Instant, YouTube and a half a dozen others.
布莱恩·里德。你可以看尤金·贾瑞奇的监狱电影《我居住的房子》。相信我，它会触动你的。它在每一个可能的互联网平台上都有——iTunes、Netflix、亚马逊即时视频、YouTube和其他六个平台。
Or you can see it by getting yourself arrested and thrown in prison, where screenings are still happening around the country. It's in New Mexico prisons next month. The film's website is thehouseilivein.org.
或者你可以通过让自己被逮捕并扔进监狱来观看，那里全国仍在进行放映。下个月它会在新墨西哥州的监狱放映。电影的网站是thehouseilivein.org。
Coming up, an insider's view of what it's like to follow love into a different and much more dangerous country than the one you live in. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
接下来，一个内部人的视角，看看跟随爱情进入一个和你居住的国家相比更不同、更危险的国家是什么感觉。一分钟后，当我们的节目继续时，来自芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。
Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show, "The View From In Here-- Insiders' Stories from Three Very Different Places."
每周我们的节目，当然，我们选择一个主题，为你带来关于该主题的各种故事。今天的节目，“来自这里的视角——来自三个非常不同地方的内部故事。”
We have arrived at Act Two of our show. Act Two, The Real Housewife of Ciudad Juarez.
我们已经到了节目的第二幕。第二幕，华雷斯城的真正主妇。
Emily Bonderer Cruz is an American. Her husband Raymundo-- she calls him Gordo-- is Mexican. When they met, he was here in the United States illegally. In fact, he had already been deported once and snuck back in.
艾米丽·邦德勒·克鲁兹（Emily Bonderer Cruz）是美国人。她的丈夫雷蒙多（Raymundo）——她称他为Gordo——是墨西哥人。当他们相遇时，他非法留在美国。事实上，他已经被驱逐出境一次，又偷偷溜了回来。
And the way that the law works, that means that the only way that he could live with her now right here in the United States with them married, is that he first needs to live outside the United States for 10 years. So after trying to live here in the States illegally for a little while, they decided they should move to Mexico. So they moved to Mexico.
按照法律运作的方式，这意味着他现在只能和她一起住在这里，在美国，他们结婚了，他首先需要在美国境外住10年。所以在试图非法留在美国住了一段时间后，他们决定应该搬到墨西哥。所以他们搬到了墨西哥。
They chose Ciudad Juarez because it's a border town. Emily could earn a US wage just by commuting into El Paso every day right across the border. And that's what she does. While Ray works at a maquila, one of the factories-- there are tons of them-- on the Mexican side of the border.
他们选择了华雷斯城，因为它是一个边境城镇。艾米丽只要每天通勤到边境对面的埃尔帕索，就能赚到美国的工资。这就是她所做的。而雷在马基拉（maquila）工作，就是边境墨西哥那一侧的工厂——那里有很多。
They moved to Juarez in 2010 at the height of the narco drug wars, when Juarez had the highest murder rate in the world, in the entire world. Emily started writing a blog about their life called The Real Housewife of Ciudad Juarez. And after reading it, radio producer Ann Heppermann gave her a recording kit and asked her just to keep a radio diary, documenting her everyday life to give the rest of us a sense of what it is like to be an American housewife right there.
他们于2010年在毒品战争最激烈的时候搬到了华雷斯，那时华雷斯的谋杀率是世界最高的，在整个世界。艾米丽开始写博客记录他们的生活，名为《华雷斯城的真正主妇》。读过之后，广播制片人安·赫伯曼（Ann Heppermann）给了她一套录音设备，让她只写广播日记，记录她的日常生活，让我们其余的人了解在美国主妇在那里是什么感觉。
OK, so we're here at the house. I'm in the living room. We're sitting on the couch. And basically I'm about to interview my husband.
好的，所以我们现在在房子里。我在客厅。我们正坐在沙发上。基本上我准备采访我的丈夫。
So I'm  just going to explain to him in Spanish. Basically, I'm going to ask him a question in Spanish, I'm going to let him go ahead and answer, and then I'm going do my best to translate. Are you ready?
所以我就用西班牙语向他解释。基本上，我要用西班牙语问他一个问题，我要让他继续回答，然后我要尽我所能翻译。你准备好了吗？
Mm mm.
嗯嗯。
[LAUGHS]. OK. [SPEAKING SPANISH] So I asked him what his version of meeting me was.
[笑]。好的。[说西班牙语] 所以我问他他认为我们相遇的版本是什么。
[LAUGHING]
[笑]
That laughter is because it's super hard to tell our version of meeting me without either of us looking like complete whores. So we generally have a filtered version of how we met each other.
那种笑声是因为如果没有我们中的任何一个人看起来像完全的荡妇，很难讲述我们相遇的我们的版本。所以我们通常有一个我们如何相遇的过滤版本。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
I met you in Mesa, Arizona.
我在亚利桑那州梅萨遇到了你。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
He's explaining that he didn't pay any attention to me because his friend was wanting to get at me, or whatever you say. So he was just kind of ignoring me and keeping his distance.
他解释说他没注意我，因为他的朋友想要追我，或者无论你怎么说。所以他只是有点忽略我，并和我保持距离。
And it's funny, because that was what I liked about-- well, I didn't like it. But I was like, doesn't he see all this?
这很有趣，因为那就是我喜欢的关于——嗯，我不喜欢它。但我当时想，他没看到所有这些吗？
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
He says he doesn't remember if it was that same day or another day that he whistled at me from down below. And that I gave him the finger wag, like come here.
他说他不记得那是同一天还是另一天，他从下面对我吹口哨。而我给了他手指摇摆，就像过来这里。
[LAUGHING]
[笑]
[WHISPERING] It was the same day. Shh. [LAUGHS]
[耳语] 那是同一天。嘘。[笑]
OK, next question. [SPEAKING SPANISH] So I asked him, how did you feel when you came back to Mexico?
好的，下一个问题。[说西班牙语] 所以我问他，当你回到墨西哥时你感觉如何？
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
I felt really weird.
我感觉非常奇怪。
You know, we drove from Arizona with our car completely packed to the brim, bikes on bike rack, crap on the top of the car.
你知道，我们从亚利桑那州开车，我们的车装得满满的，自行车架上有自行车，车顶上有垃圾。
And I drove. It's a six-hour trip from Phoenix to El Paso. And the whole time I was driving, I mean my hands were just clenched to the steering wheel so hard. I was sweating.
而且是我开的车。从菲尼克斯到埃尔帕索有六小时的车程。我开车的时候，我是说我的手紧紧地抓住方向盘。我在出汗。
It was August. August 7 of 2010. And for me, it was really emotional when I saw Juarez for the first time.
那是八月。2010年8月7日。对我来说，当我第一次看到华雷斯时，真的很感伤。
It's a pretty bad area right there. A lot of the roads aren't paved. Quiet tears rolling down my face. And I'm just praying to God that my husband doesn't notice that I'm crying, because I didn't want him to feel bad.
那里是一个非常糟糕的区域。很多路都没有铺设。静静的眼泪顺着我的脸流下。我只是在向上帝祈祷我的丈夫没有注意到我在哭，因为我不想让他感觉糟糕。
I mean, the whole time it was my idea to move to Mexico. I couldn't back down now. And I went into this like, I could live in a shack. I love this man. I don't care where we live.
我是说，整个过程搬到墨西哥是我的主意。我现在不能退缩了。我进入了这种状态，比如，我可以住在棚屋里。我爱这个男人。我不在乎我们住在哪里。
I don't need air conditioning, cable. I don't need internet. I can just do this.
我不需要空调、有线电视。我不需要互联网。我只是可以做到。
[LAUGHING]
[笑]
[LAUGHING] OK, we gotta power through these last questions because his novela is starting in eight minutes.
[笑] 好的，我们必须努力完成这些最后的问题，因为他的肥皂剧要在八分钟后开始了。
[BELCHES]
[打嗝]
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
Oh, I'm sorry. Excuse me. Excuse me.
哦，对不起。抱歉。抱歉。
[LAUGHING] OK. [SPEAKING SPANISH] I'm going to ask him how he feels about working in the maquilas now. [SPEAKING SPANISH]
[笑] 好的。[说西班牙语] 我要问他现在对于在马基拉工作感觉如何。[说西班牙语]
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
Well, I feel good.
嗯，我感觉不错。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
But the bad part is the pay. That's really the only bad part. [SPEAKING SPANISH]
但糟糕的部分是工资。那真的是唯一糟糕的部分。[说西班牙语]
And then I ask him, how do you feel since your wife earns more than you do and pays the majority of the bills? How does that make you feel?
然后我问他，自从你的妻子赚的比你多并支付大部分账单以来，你感觉如何？那让你感觉如何？
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
Well, I feel-- how could I say?
嗯，我感觉——我该怎么说？
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
I feel a little bit bad.
我感觉有点不好。
[SPEAKING SPANISH] [LAUGHS]
[说西班牙语] [笑]
I can really only pay the water. No. [SPEAKING SPANISH]
我真的只能支付水费。不。[说西班牙语]
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
But--
但——
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
I put a little part in there.
我在那里放了一小部分。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
My part's really small but--
我的部分真的很小但——
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
I'm proud of my part. I'm going to ask him how this move or self-deportation has affected our marriage. And does he think it's been hard on our marriage? [SPEAKING  SPANISH]
我为我的部分感到骄傲。我要问他这次搬迁或自我驱逐出境对我们的婚姻有何影响。他认为这对我们的婚姻很难吗？[说西班牙语]
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
To begin, it felt a little bit bad. But now it feels better and it's not as big of a deal. And you know, we're here.
开始时，感觉有点不好。但现在感觉更好，而且没那么大不了了。而且你知道，我们在这里。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
We're living the best life in the world. We're happy. He's fist pumping. [LAUGHS]
我们过着世界上最好的生活。我们很幸福。他在挥拳。[笑]
Pumping?
挥拳？
Fist pumping. [SPEAKING SPANISH] The Jersey Shore ?
挥拳。[说西班牙语] 《泽西海岸》（Jersey Shore）？
[SPEAKING SPANISH]? [HUMMING] No? [SPEAKING SPANISH]?
[说西班牙语]？[哼唱] 不？[说西班牙语]？
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
[LAUGHS] He said that was the easiest question I asked him.
[笑] 他说这是我问他的最简单的问题。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
You rock.
你真棒。
[SPEAKING SPANISH] [LAUGHS]. [SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语] [笑]。[说西班牙语]
Oh, I really love my husband. He's just like the man I always wanted.
哦，我真的很爱我的丈夫。他就像我一直想要的那个男人。
You know like you hear those songs? Like Third Eye Blind is my favorite band. So you always listen to those songs and you hear about these guys that just love a woman so much. I want to fall asleep inside of you. I mean, you've heard that lyric, right?
你知道就像你听那些歌吗？比如第三只眼盲乐队（Third Eye Blind）是我最喜欢的乐队。所以你总是听那些歌，你听到关于那些仅仅是非常爱一个女人的男人。我想要在你的身体里睡着。我是说，你听过那句歌词，对吗？
And it's like, you go after that person that's like that and that's romantic right off the bat like that and it never ends up being a Third Eye Blind song. But I've came to find years down the road that's not really what I wanted.
就像是，你去追那个像那样的人，那个浪漫一开始就是那样的，但它从来不会成为第三只眼盲乐队的歌。但我发现几年后那并不是我真正想要的。
I wanted someone to say, oh, you have someone coming over? Do you want me to take something out of the freezer for dinner? Or somebody that mops the floor because I have to work late or whatever. That's really what made me go to Mexico is taking out the trash.
我想要有人说，哦，你有客人要来吗？你想让我从冷冻室拿些东西出来做晚餐吗？或者有人在拖地，因为我必须加班之类。那真的是让我去墨西哥的原因，就是倒垃圾。
OK, testies, testies. Un, dos, tres. OK, so I'm in line and it's only 6:44, so you can see how fast I got in line from downtown El Paso.
好的，测试，测试。一、二、三。好的，所以我在线路里，现在才6:44，所以你可以看到我从埃尔帕索市中心排队有多快。
I feel like I have a song for this. 'Cause not only is it Friday, but I got paid today. OK, this is my perfect song for payday Friday.
我觉得我有一首歌适合这个。因为不仅是星期五，而且我今天发薪水了。好的，这是我发薪日星期五的完美歌曲。
[MUSIC - "GET DRUNK AND BE SOMEBODY" BY TOBY KEITH]
[音乐 - 托比·基斯（Toby Keith）的《去喝醉成为某个人》（Get Drunk And Be Somebody）]
Friday, baby! Literally one speed bump out of this joint, I'm in Mexico.
星期五，宝贝！从这个地方走一个减速带，我就在墨西哥了。
This is my hood. I love this neighborhood. It's like the perfect mixture of America and Mexico to me. Because I'm not so hardcore pioneer that I could really do real Mexico.
这是我的街区。我爱这个街区。对我来说这就像美国和墨西哥的完美混合。因为我不是那么铁杆的先驱，我真的能过真正的墨西哥生活。
I mean, I guess maybe I could. I just don't have the balls or I don't know, the ovaries, to live on a ranch or not have running water or whatever.
我是说，我想也许我可以。我只是没有胆量或者我不知道，卵巢，去住在牧场或者没有自来水什么的。
And there's other things that I just like to have. Like an oven, for instance. Those are privileges here. And I definitely have those things at my house and I really enjoy that. And that's something I love about my neighborhood.
还有其他我只是喜欢拥有的东西。比如烤箱，例如。那些在这里是特权。我绝对在我房子里有那些东西，我真的很享受。这也是我喜欢关于我的街区的一点。
I'm in line right now at Beep Beep to buy cigarettes. I'm not quite sure how they're going to react to the microphone thing, but I'm just not going to mention it and see what happens.
我正在Beep Beep排队买香烟。我不确定他们会对麦克风的事情做出什么反应，但我只是不打算提它，看看会发生什么。
[BELL RINGS]
[铃声]
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
Si, por favor. Well, he said absolutely nothing about the giant microphone in front of my face. Which sometimes, see? We're just paranoid in Juarez for no reason whatsoever.
是的，请。嗯，他关于我脸前巨大的麦克风什么都没说。有时，你看？我们在华雷斯只是毫无理由地偏执。
13 days after we had gotten to Juarez, we went to turn into the street to get to my house and we couldn't. There were federal police everywhere.
我们到华雷斯13天后，我们去转进那条街要去我家，我们进不去。到处都是联邦警察。
And then I saw him. His body, it was lying there on the ground. I remember his knees were bent very awkwardly. It was really not natural. There was blood everywhere.
然后我看到了他。他的身体，它就在地上。我记得他的膝盖弯曲得非常尴尬。真的不自然。到处都是血。
And I started to cry. That was 13 days after we moved to Juarez. That was the first and last time I cried over a dead body. But I remember that day thinking, what else am I going to see in 10 years here? [SIGH].
我开始哭。那是在我们搬到华雷斯13天后。那是我第一次也是最后一次为一个死人哭。但我记得那天想，我在这10年里还会看到什么？[叹气]。
There's a new man selling newspapers right there. He puts his stool right over that blood stain and goes on with his life, sells the paper. Juarez has to keep chugging along, regardless of what happens.
有一个新人在那儿卖报纸。他把他的凳子放在那个血迹上，继续他的生活，卖报纸。华雷斯必须继续前进，无论发生什么。
So I'm home now. Get my chicken that I smuggled.
所以我现在在家了。拿到我走私的鸡。
[CAR DOOR SLAMS]
[车门关上]
[CAR ALARM CHIRPS]
[车警报声]
And then it's time to open like 700 gates. That's a lie. There's just one gate.
然后是时候打开700个门了。那是谎话。只有一个门。
I have to have a key card to get in the neighborhood and then I have to have three keys to get into the house. And you gotta lock everything behind you, of course. And then probably we already locked the car, but--
我必须有一张钥匙卡才能进这个社区，然后我必须有三把钥匙才能进房子。而且你必须在你身后锁好所有东西，当然。然后可能我们已经锁好了车，但——
[CAR ALARM CHIRPS]
[车警报声]
Lock it again.
再锁一次。
[DOGS BARKING]
[狗叫声]
My puppies are barking. They miss me. Hi! Oh, my babies.
我的小狗在叫。它们想我了。嗨！哦，我的宝贝们。
[DOG  GROANING]
[狗呻吟]
Baby! Ray! Mi amor!
宝贝！雷！我的爱人！
OK, so tonight-- and this is a typical Saturday night-- Gordo and his friend Milon are outside right now, listening to music and getting their drink on. I'm in here making some chicken, because I needed to make it before it went bad.
好的，所以今晚——这是一个典型的星期六晚上——Gordo和他的朋友Milon现在在外面，听音乐和喝酒。我在这里做些鸡肉，因为我需要在它坏掉之前做。
In Juarez, this is what we do. So they're going to sit outside and drink and listen to music. It's like in the country, but with bullets! [LAUGHS]
在华雷斯，这就是我们做的。所以他们要坐在外面喝酒听音乐。就像在乡下，但有子弹！[笑]
People always joke about it, but I rarely hear bullets. Gunshots I guess is what they're called. You don't just hear bullets.
人们总是开玩笑，但我很少听到子弹。我想枪声就是他们被叫做的。你不仅仅听到子弹。
[MEN LAUGHING]
[男人笑声]
For me, it makes me happy that he can go and live a normal life that he couldn't live in the US. Or that I guess he could have, but it would've been so risky. You know, driving and paying for things that he couldn't do in the US. And even though he makes way less money here, he can be more of a man without having that income in other ways.
对我来说，让我高兴的是他能去过一种在美国无法过的正常生活。或者我想他可以，但那会风险很大。你知道，开车和支付一些在美国不能做的事情。尽管他在这里赚的钱少得多，他可以作为一个男人，而没有其他方式的收入。
[BLOWING INTO  MICROPHONE]
[对着麦克风吹气]
Hello? Well, I was going to go sleep. But crying a little bit.
喂？嗯，我本来要睡觉了。但哭了一点。
You know, just when I think that I have--
你知道，就在我以为我有——
[LIGHTS CIGARETTE]
[点烟]
At times I feel so caught up in immigration. And the idea that we've been slighted in some way.
有时我觉得如此被移民所困。以及我们被以某种方式轻视的想法。
And lately, I don't really feel that way. My husband did break the law and this is the result of laws that were put in place with good intentions. And now what I want to concentrate on is my life here.
最近，我真的不那样觉得了。我的丈夫确实违反了法律，这是以善意实施的法律的结果。现在我想专注于我在这里的生活。
This is my life. I can't change the law. I mean, I marched in protest rallies and I was involved in immigration reform and I was a member of different groups and talked to congressmen. And I did all those things for all these years while we were in the US.
这是我的生活。我不能改变法律。我是说，我参加了抗议集会，我参与了移民改革，我曾是不同团体的成员，也和国会议员交谈过。我在美国时多年来做了所有那些事情。
And when we got here, it was just like a weight had been lifted off my shoulder. Because I didn't have to [INAUDIBLE] deal with any of that anymore. I didn't have to think about my husband getting picked up by ICE on our way to church or whatever.
当我们来到这里时，就像一个重担从我的肩上卸了下来。因为我不必[听不清]再处理任何那些事情了。我不必考虑我丈夫在我们去教堂的路上被ICE带走之类的事。
I mean, the most simple, mundane activities in the US always had to involve some thought about immigration. And it might be a cop out just because I don't want to talk about immigration. I don't want to think about it. I don't want to argue with anybody that it's not fair. I just don't feel like doing it.
我是说，在美国最简单、平凡的活动总是必须涉及一些关于移民的想法。而这可能是一个借口，仅仅因为我不想谈论移民。我不想去想它。我不想和任何人争论它不公平。我只是不想做它。
I'm tired. I'm really, really tired. You know. And I don't know. Goodnight.
我累了。我真的，真的累了。你知道。我不知道。晚安。
This feels extremely too loud for what time it is. It's 5:45. I take Gordo to work first.
这感觉对现在的时间来说太吵了。是5:45。我先送Gordo去上班。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
[LAUGHS] He says he doesn't talk in the mornings. He's making fun of me because I don't talk in the mornings. I hate talking in the morning.
[笑] 他说他在早晨不说话。他在取笑我，因为我在早晨不说话。我讨厌在早晨说话。
So we're on Hermanos Escobar now. And we're behind a line of buses. They're all going to a maquila somewhere.
所以我们现在在Hermanos Escobar。我们在排队的公交车后面。它们都在去某个地方的马基拉。
When I look at people going in and out of the maquilas, I just see a little dollar sign on everyone's forehead. Because they most certainly make a ton of money off these poor people who are working for-- god, I don't even know what they make. It's like $0.80 an hour or something that he makes. I don't even think it's that, actually. What?
当我看着人们进进出出马基拉时，我只是看到每个人的额头上有一个小美元符号。因为他们最肯定是从这些工作的人身上赚了成吨的钱，工作为了——天哪，我甚至不知道他们赚多少。就像每小时0.80美元或者是他赚的什么。我甚至不认为实际上是那样。什么？
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
[SPEAKING SPANISH ANGRILY]
[愤怒地用西班牙语说]
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
And thankfully, we're dropping him off. Have a good day!
值得庆幸的是，我们要送他下车了。祝你有美好的一天！
Bye!
拜！
[CAR DOOR SLAMS]
[车门关上]
[LAUGHS] We're so not morning people. We'll have the most horrible fights in the morning.
[笑] 我们真不是早起的人。我们会在早晨进行最可怕的争吵。
So I just dropped him off at the maquila. And he'll work there all day long. He makes the harnesses for American cars.
所以我刚刚把他送到马基拉。他整天都会在那里工作。他制造美国汽车的线束。
And now we're going to the bridge. There is literally no line. Oh, I'm so excited. The line can go back a couple miles on a normal day, but I'm pulling right up onto the bridge. And I'm here. [YAWNS]
现在我们要去桥那里了。真的没有队伍。哦，我太激动了。在正常的一天，队伍可以排到几英里远，但我正拉上桥。我到了。[打哈欠]
The basic routine is first texting my husband. At the end of the day, this is Juarez and we have to make sure I didn't die. I mean, seriously.
基本的常规是先发短信给我丈夫。在一天结束时，这是华雷斯，我们必须确保我没死。我是说，真的。
[BEEP]
[哔]
Gordo just texted me back to have a good day. [LAUGHS] We really just should not be talking to each other in the morning. It's detrimental to everything.
Gordo刚刚回信祝我有个美好的一天。[笑] 我们真的不应该在早晨互相交谈。这对一切都有害。
So basic routine is texting. And then makeup, social networking, maybe social networking, makeup, social networking. It's pretty basic. Mascara.
所以基本的常规是发短信。然后化妆，社交网络，也许社交网络，化妆，社交网络。很基本。睫毛膏。
[TAPPING]
[敲击]
Eyeshadow. OK, I'm still doing my makeup. I'm almost about to cross already, though. It's always kind of fun to see the new agents confused about the white lady.
眼影。好的，我还在化妆。虽然我快要过境了。看到新的特工对那个白人女士感到困惑总是很有趣。
Morning!
早安！
Morning, ma'am. Where you going today?
早安，女士。你今天去哪儿？
Work.
工作。
What are you bringing from Mexico?
你从墨西哥带了什么？
Nothing.
什么都没有。
Have a good day.
祝你有美好的一天。
Thank you. You too.
谢谢。你也一样。
Thank you.
谢谢。
And that was that. So it's 6:21 and I don't go to work until 8 o'clock. So now I have like an hour and a half before I really [YAWNS] need to be at work. So I'm going to go to sleep. [LAUGHS]
就是这样。现在是6:21，我直到8点才上班。所以我现在有大约一个半小时，在我真的[打哈欠]需要去上班之前。所以我打算去睡觉。[笑]
This is what I do. You have only a handful of options. You can go to Walmart, which is a very popular option. You can go to McDonald's, another very popular option. Or you can go to sleep in your car.
这就是我做的。你只有少数选择。你可以去沃尔玛，这是一个非常受欢迎的选择。你可以去麦当劳，另一个非常受欢迎的选择。或者你可以去你的车里睡觉。
And that, my friends, is what I'm going to do. And I have a little handful of parking lots that I frequent. But my favorite is this golf course by my work. It's really quiet and there's a public pool there.
而那，我的朋友，就是我打算做的。我有几个我经常去的停车场。但我最喜欢的是我工作旁边的这个高尔夫球场。它真的很安静，那里有一个公共游泳池。
And I think there's a swimming class at 6:30. But it lasts a couple of hours. So I wonder if they think I'm homeless. I think about things  like that way too much.
我想6:30有一个游泳课。但它持续几个小时。所以我想知道他们是否认为我无家可归。我想那样的事情想太多了。
It's hard to say what Juarez really means to me. It's everything for us. To me, Juarez is the perfect combination of heaven and hell on Earth.
很难说华雷斯对我真正意味着什么。它是我们的一切。对我来说，华雷斯是地球上天堂和地狱的完美结合。
Despite this raging drug war going on, despite all of the bad things in the city, it's the first place that's ever opened its arms to my husband and I, the first place we can both legally call home. And it's our own little paradise. [YAWNS] [LAUGHS] So tired.
尽管发生了这场猖獗的毒品战争，尽管城市里有所有糟糕的事情，这是第一个向我和我丈夫张开双臂的地方，第一个我们都能合法地称之为家的地方。这是我们自己的小天堂。[打哈欠] [笑] 太累了。
OK, so I'm going to go to my little golf course and fall asleep. I have my pillow and my blanket that I keep in the car. And that's that.
好的，所以我打算去我的小高尔夫球场睡觉了。我有我放在车里的枕头和毯子。就是这样。
Oh my gosh, what a beautiful sunrise. Gosh.
哦天哪，多么美丽的日出。天哪。
Emily Bonderer Cruz. Her radio diary was produced by Ann Heppermann with help from Debbie Nathan.
艾米丽·邦德勒·克鲁兹。她的广播日记由安·赫伯曼在黛比·内森（Debbie Nathan）的帮助下制作。
To read Emily's blog, go to therealhousewifeofcuidadjuarez.blogspot.com. Emily has chosen some favorite posts from her site that we linked to from our website, thisamericanlife.org.
要阅读艾米丽的博客，请前往therealhousewifeofcuidadjuarez.blogspot.com。艾米丽从她的网站上挑选了一些最喜欢的帖子，我们在我们的网站thisamericanlife.org上链接了这些帖子。
Act Three, Moving On Up. In Israel there's this writer named Sayed Kashua who's a prolific cultural force in that country. He's a novelist. He writes a popular, very funny TV show, where the main character is based on him. And he has a weekly newspaper column.
第三幕，向上移动。在以色列有一位名叫赛义德·卡什亚（Sayed Kashua）的作家，他是该国多产的文化力量。他是一位小说家。他写了一部流行、非常有趣的电视节目，其中的主角就是以他为原型的。他还有一个每周报纸专栏。
And his newspaper columns are basically this very frank, very entertaining conversation he's been having with the entire country for years now. They're about his day-to-day life. Picking up his kids, buying furniture, stuff like that.
他的报纸专栏基本上是他多年来一直与整个国家进行的非常坦率、非常有趣的对话。它们是关于他的日常生活。接他的孩子，买家具，之类的东西。
And while the columns are not explicitly political, he's a minority in Israel. He's an Arab who is also an Israeli citizen. Which, as you might expect, is complicated.
虽然这些专栏不是明确的政治性的，但他以色列的少数派。他是一名也是以色列公民的阿拉伯人。这，正如你可能预料的，是复杂的。
A few years ago, Kashua and his wife and kids moved from East Jerusalem-- where most of the Arabs in the city live-- to West Jerusalem, where it's almost all Jews, no Arabs. And that kind of blew people's minds, including his.
几年前，卡什亚和他的妻子以及孩子从东耶路撒冷——该市大多数阿拉伯人居住的地方——搬到了西耶路撒冷，那里几乎全是犹太人，没有阿拉伯人。这让人们感到震惊，包括他自己。
He and his wife made the move to get a better apartment in a neighborhood that had better services. But the move was radical in a country where even middle class and rich Arab Israelis do not usually live among Jews, especially in Jerusalem.
他和他的妻子搬家是为了在设施更好的社区获得更好的公寓。但这种搬迁在一个即使中产阶级和富裕的以色列阿拉伯人通常也不住在一起的地方，尤其是在耶路撒冷，是激进的。
His columns are reports from the kind of citizen that every country has, the insider outsider. Here are excerpts from those columns translated from Hebrew and read by actor Ramsey Faragallah.
他的专栏是来自每个国家都有的那种公民的报告，内部外部人。这里是由演员拉姆齐·法拉加拉（Ramsey Faragallah）从希伯来语翻译并朗读的那些专栏的摘录。
October 18, 2012. It was the coffee machine that ultimately shed new light on my social situation. As usual, it all started because of my wife.
2012年10月18日。正是咖啡机最终让我对我的社会状况有了新的认识。和往常一样，这一切都始于我的妻子。
Don't get me wrong. I can be a real jerk, but I do love my wife. Today more than ever.
别误解我。我可能是一个真正的混蛋，但我确实爱我的妻子。今天比以往任何时候都更爱。
I've mentioned before that our apartment suddenly started to get on her nerves. At first there were trivial comments like, "These shower hooks are really annoying," or "There's not even a proper place for the shoe closet," even though we never had a shoe closet.
我以前提过我们公寓突然开始让她紧张。起初有一些琐碎的评论，比如，“这些淋浴钩真的很烦人，”或“甚至没有鞋柜的合适地方，”即使我们从来没有过鞋柜。
The complaints gathered momentum after our third child was born. "I think we need another room for the baby." "We have to paint. Have you seen the walls? They're already black from the kids' hands."
在我们的第三个孩子出生后，抱怨声愈演愈烈。“我想我们需要另一个房间给宝宝。”“我们必须刷墙。你看到墙了吗？它们已经因为孩子的手而变黑了。”
Very quickly, the home that I loved so much, in the building I love, in the neighborhood I love became a nightmare. So I asked my wife, "What do you say to renovating?"
很快，我非常喜欢的家，在我喜欢的建筑里，在我喜欢的街区，变成了一场噩梦。所以我问我的妻子，“你觉得翻新怎么样？”
I don't know how or why, but of the three renovating teams who were bidding to just basically build a plaster wall and paint the place, I found myself choosing the team that gave me a price three times higher than that of any of the others, an Ashkenazi architect with a Mizrahi interior designer. Maybe it was the iPad that the interior designer used when he presented the work plan. Or maybe it was just because every time he said "plaster wall, " he added the adjective "designer."
我不知道怎么或为什么，但在三个投标只是基本上建造一个石膏墙并粉刷那个地方的翻新团队中，我发现自己选择了那个报价比其他任何一个都高三倍的团队，一位带有米兹拉希室内设计师的阿什肯纳兹建筑师。也许是因为室内设计师在展示工作计划时使用的iPad。或者也许仅仅是因为每次他说“石膏墙”时，他都加上了形容词“设计师”。
I closed the deal with the Ashkenazi, who promised to go with my wife to all the stores to choose the color of the designer plaster wall, pick out the shoe closet, and find the hooks that best suited her needs. Because the most important thing in interior design is for the house to meet your needs, said the interior designer, pointing at my wife.
我和阿什肯纳兹达成了协议，他承诺去和我的妻子去所有的商店选择设计师石膏墙的颜色，挑选鞋柜，并找到最适合她需求的钩子。因为室内设计中最重要的事情是房子要满足你的需求，室内设计师说，指着我的妻子。
"14,000 shekels for a paint job!" my father shouted at me. "For what? On every electricity pole there is a sign, paint your home for 1,800 shekels."
“油漆工作要14,000谢克尔！”我父亲对我大喊。“为了什么？在每一根电线杆上都有一个标志，粉刷你的家要1,800谢克尔。”
"What 1,800 shekels?" I said. "And anyway, we're talking about designer paint, Dad!"
“什么1,800谢克尔？”我说。“而且无论如何，我们谈论的是设计师油漆，爸爸！”
My father still lives in the village where I grew up, Tira. He tried to explain to me that I'm an imbecile. That in Tira, you could get a new shower and a paint job with a plaster wall, even a designer one, for a tenth of the price.
我父亲仍然住在我成长的村庄，提拉（Tira）。他试图向我解释我是个白痴。在提拉，你可以以十分之一的价格得到一个新的淋浴和带石膏墙的油漆工作，甚至是一个设计师的。
I tried to explain to him that I don't live in Tira, that the interior designer promised that the finished work would last a lifetime. And that anyway, there was nothing that could be done about it. Life in West Jerusalem in my neighborhood costs a little more, with all due respect to Tira.
我试图向他解释我不住在提拉，室内设计师承诺完成的工作会持续一生。而且无论如何，对此无能为力。在我街区的西耶路撒冷生活成本更高，对提拉的所有应有的尊重。
"You're a dunce," my father concluded. "Do what you like."
“你是个笨蛋，”我父亲总结道。“做你喜欢的。”
I felt like making coffee. At least I wanted to, but the milk frother in the machine-- which you have to belong to an exclusive customer club in order to use-- had stopped working. I called customer service.
我想喝咖啡。至少我想，但机器里的奶泡器——你必须属于一个独家客户俱乐部才能使用它——已经停止工作了。我拨打了客服。
"That's right," I was told after a lengthy hold. "The machine is still under warranty." It would be picked up for repair within three working days.
“没错，”在长时间的等待后，我被告知。“机器仍在保修期内。”它将在三个工作日内被取走维修。
In the meantime, while I was waiting for the coffee machine, I realized that the plaster wall and paint job had morphed into a replacement of old doors, installation of an entirely new air conditioning system called something like Inventor, and the sudden urgent need for a new bedroom set whose size would be compatible with the modern design. "Adjustable, " my wife called it.
同时，当我等待咖啡机时，我意识到石膏墙和油漆工作已经演变成了更换旧门，安装一个名为Inventor之类东西的全新空调系统，以及对一套现代设计兼容尺寸的新卧室家具的突然紧急需求。“可调节，”我的妻子称之为。
The interior designer also suggested moving the piano to a different location, and building an acoustic wall that would contain the sound. And he proposed that I please put some life into my anemic study. And I agreed, even though I didn't understand exactly what that meant.
室内设计师还建议将钢琴移动到不同的位置，并建造一个包含声音的声学墙。他还建议我请为我贫血的研究室注入一些生活。我同意了，尽管我不完全理解那意味着什么。
His iPad has a calculator, and a few quick clicks produced the sum of more than 100,000 shekels, not counting the shoe closet. It took me a moment to recall that I had intended to spend no more than 20,000 shekels. I lapsed into depression, because I had already made the down payment and because I didn't want to tell my wife that we might not be able to meet the future payments. So I said nothing, and she gave me a designer smile such as I hadn't seen for a few years.
他的iPad有一个计算器，几次快速点击就产生了超过100,000谢克尔的总和，不计算鞋柜。我花了一会儿才想起我打算花费不超过20,000谢克尔。我陷入了抑郁，因为我已经支付了首付，而且因为我不想告诉我的妻子我们可能无法支付未来的费用。所以我什么也没说，她给了我一个我几年没见过的设计师微笑。
A few days later, on the day when we were supposed to get our prestigious coffee machine back from repairs between 5:00 and 7:00 PM, she said, "Do you  know what's most unsuited to my needs in this apartment?" "Yes," I said. "All the inconvenient things. But everything is going to be fine."
几天后，在我们应该从维修中拿回我们久负盛名的咖啡机的那天，在下午5:00到7:00之间，她说，“你知道这间公寓里最不适合我需求的是什么吗？”“是的，”我说。“所有不方便的事情。但一切都会好起来的。”
"No," she said. "I think I'm deceiving myself with all this new design and renovation."
“不，”她说。“我觉得我用所有这些新设计和翻新来欺骗自己。”
"I don't understand," I said, genuinely not understanding.
“我不明白，”我说，真正不明白。
"What bothers me the most," she said, "is that since we've moved here, you haven't wanted to barbecue. I so much want you to barbecue like we used to back in the village every Friday."
“最困扰我的是，”她说，“因为自从我们搬到这里，你就不想烧烤了。我非常希望你像我们以前在村子里每个星期五那样烧烤。”
"Barbecue?" I felt my blood pressure rising. "I'm going to spend $100,000 shekels for an interior designer and all you really want is a barbecue?"
“烧烤？”我感到我的血压升高。“我要花100,000谢克尔请室内设计师，而你真正想要的只是烧烤？”
"Well," she said, "I miss the village. And the days when you weren't embarrassed to barbecue next to the neighbors." At that point, the phone rang.
“嗯，”她说，“我想念村庄。还有那些你不为在邻居旁边烧烤感到尴尬的日子。”就在那时，电话响了。
"Hello," the voice on the phone said as I started to foam at the mouth. "I'm from the delivery company. I have a coffee machine for you. What's the address?" he asked in Arabic.
“喂，”当我开始口吐白沫时，电话里的声音说。“我来自快递公司。我为你有一台咖啡机。地址是多少？”他用阿拉伯语问。
I gave him the address. He was silent for a while. And then he said, "But I only deliver in East Jerusalem. I'm sorry. I was told you were an Arab."
我给了他地址。他沉默了一会儿。然后他说，“但我只在东耶路撒冷送货。抱歉。有人告诉我你是个阿拉伯人。”
"You know what?" I replied in Arabic, "Forget it. I don't want the espresso machine. I don't even like that kind of coffee."
“你知道吗？”我用阿拉伯语回答，“算了。我不要浓缩咖啡机。我甚至不喜欢那种咖啡。”
November 22, 2012. The renovations have begun. The apartment is in chaos and I've decided that I'm going to buy the most comfortable bed I can find, and this time I won't even look at the price.
2012年11月22日。翻新已经开始了。公寓一片混乱，我决定我要买我能找到的最舒适的床，这次我甚至不会看价格。
I picked up my wife from work and we went to buy the bed of our dreams. "We want the most comfortable bed you have in the store," I declared to the saleswoman who approached us with a smile.
我接我妻子下班，我们去买我们梦想的床。“我们要店里你能有的最舒适的床，”我向带着微笑走向我们的女售货员宣布。
"Of course," she said, leading us to the area of the double beds. "Are you interested in an adjustable bed?"
“当然，”她说，带领我们到双人床区域。“你对可调节床感兴趣吗？”
"Only adjustable," I declared festively. And the polite saleswoman smiled once again and accompanied us to the area of the adjustables.
“只可调节，”我节日般地宣布。礼貌的女售货员再次微笑，陪我们到可调节区域。
"Ah," I sighed as I sprawled on the mattress and closed my eyes.
“啊，”我躺在床垫上闭上眼睛时叹了口气。
"We also have it in 6 and 1/2 feet wide."
“我们也6.5英尺宽。”
"6 and 1/2 feet, hmm." I said to the saleswoman. "Exactly how much does the same bed cost in that size?" When she told me, I shouted. "How much?"
“6.5英尺，嗯。”我对女售货员说。“那个尺寸同样的床到底要多少钱？”当她告诉我时，我大喊。“多少？”
"I'll ask the store manager. Maybe he can give you a better price," she said.
“我会问店经理。也许他能给你一个更好的价格，”她说。
"That's insane," I said to my wife when the saleswoman went to call the manager. "All that money for what? For foam, a few springs, and the remote control of a toy racing car?"
“这太疯狂了，”当女售货员去给经理打电话时，我对我的妻子说。“所有的钱为了什么？为了泡沫，几根弹簧，和玩具赛车的遥控器？”
"You said you didn't care about the price," she said. "Why do you even bother making declarations like that?"
“你说你不在乎价格，”她说。“为什么你甚至还要费心做出那样的声明？”
"Why? Did I think those were going to be the prices? I was willing to waste up to 5,000 shekels. And I thought that for 4,000 shekels, I would be able to get the best mattress on the market."
“为什么？我以为那是会是那个价格？我愿意浪费高达5,000谢克尔。我以为对于4,000谢克尔，我就能买到市场上最好的床垫。”
"Well, apparently this is the real price of mattresses," she said.
“嗯，显然这就是床垫的真实价格，”她说。
"Shalom," said the store manager, who came up to us with an amazingly wide smile. He introduced himself and offered his hand, and I introduced myself when I shook his hand.
“沙洛姆（Shalom，你好），”店经理说，他带着惊人的宽大微笑向我们走来。他自我介绍并伸出手，当我握手时我介绍了自己。
"Pleased to meet you, 'Sa-eed,'" he continued in Hebrew, mispronouncing my name. I didn't correct him. Neither did my wife.
“很高兴见到你，‘Sa-eed’，”他继续用希伯来语说，误读了我的名字。我没有纠正他。我的妻子也没有。
He was quite nice, the manager, despite the prices he was asking. And he had a slight speech problem. He spoke very slowly, emphasizing each letter and nodding his head after every word.
他相当不错，经理，尽管他要求的价格。他有一个轻微的言语问题。他说话非常慢，强调每个字母，并在每个词后点头。
(SPEAKING SLOWLY) "You know about this mattress?" he asked, naming the brand that every child in Israel is familiar with.
（慢速说话）“你知道这个床垫吗？”他问，列举了以色列每个孩子都熟悉的品牌。
"Yes," I replied in the same vein out of politeness, so he wouldn't think, god forbid, that my fast speech was meant to mock him. (SPEAKING SLOWLY) "We've heard about that mattress."
“是的，”我出于礼貌用同样的方式回答，这样他就不会想，上帝保佑，我的快速说话是为了嘲笑他。（慢速说话）“我们听说过那个床垫。”
"So you know which store you've come to?" He smiled and nodded.
“所以你知道你来到哪个店了吗？”他微笑着点头。
"Yes," I answered, and nodded too, smiling slowly.
“是的，”我回答，也点头，微笑着慢慢地。
I liked him, that manager. I also liked the chain for not hesitating to hire a manager with a speech impediment. I was already thinking of buying the mattress, although I had planned to spend a quarter of that amount. But it would be worth it to support a business whose owners are, first of all, human beings.
我喜欢他，那个经理。我也喜欢这个连锁店不犹豫雇佣一个有言语障碍的经理。我已经想买那个床垫了，尽管我计划只花那个金额的四分之一。但支持一个其所有者首先是人类的企业是值得的。
Suddenly he stopped talking to answer the cellphone that was ringing in his pants pockets. "Hello!" he answered with a speed that left me and my wife amazed. "Moshe, I'll get back to you in 15 minutes. [INAUDIBLE]. Bye." And he hung up.
突然他停止说话去接他在裤子口袋里响的手机。“喂！”他回答时速度惊人，让我和我的妻子感到惊奇。“莫舍（Moshe），我15分钟后回你。[听不清]。拜。”他挂了。
(SPEAKING SLOWLY) "So where were we?" he continued slowly while nodding. I looked at my wife, who looked back at me. "Ah yes," he said. "The mattress."
（慢速说话）“所以我们在哪里？”他慢慢继续，同时点头。我看着我的妻子，她看着我。“啊是的，”他说。“床垫。”
"Listen," I said to him at top speed. "Listen, we know what this damn mattress is. Do you understand?"
“听着，”我以最高速度对他说。“听着，我们知道这个该死的床垫是什么。你明白吗？”
"Yes," he answered in a panic. "But why are you angry?"
“是的，”他在恐慌中回答。“但你为什么生气？”
"Because we may be Arabs," I answered irritably, "but we aren't idiots!"
“因为我们可能是阿拉伯人，”我恼怒地回答，“但我们不是白痴！”
"God forbid!" apologized the manager, putting his hand on his chest. "I definitely didn't mean that! I really didn't. I'm sorry if that's how it seemed to you!"
“上帝保佑！”经理道歉，把手放在胸前。“我绝对没那个意思！我真的没有。如果你觉得那样，我很抱歉！”
My wife took her bag and decided that we weren't buying anything from someone like him. "Not on your life!" I said as we started making our way out of the store. "Racist idiot!"
我的妻子拿上她的包，决定我们不从像他这样的人那里买任何东西。“一辈子都不会！”我说，当我们开始走出店门时。“种族主义白痴！”
"Wait!", he chased after us. "I apologize!"
“等一下！”他追我们。“我道歉！”
"Forget it," I answered firmly. "We're not doing business with someone like you!"
“算了，”我坚定地回答。“我们不和像你这样的人做生意！”
"I'll give you a big discount," he pleaded.
“我给你一个大折扣，”他恳求。
"Forget about it," said my wife. "It's not a matter of discount. It's a matter of principle."
“算了吧，”我的妻子说。“这不是折扣的问题。这是原则的问题。”
"Look, I'll take off 25%. What do you say?"
“看，我去掉25%。你觉得怎么样？”
"I said no," said my wife, with the determination of a social worker who believes that a principle is a principle.
“我说不，”我的妻子说，有着相信原则就是原则的社会工作者的决心。
"I'll give it to you for half price!" insisted the manager, who really was sorry that he had spoken slowly.
“我半价给你们！”经理坚持说，他真的很抱歉他说话慢了。
"Principles are principles," continued my wife on her way out of the store, while I stopped in my tracks.
“原则就是原则，”我的妻子在走出商店的路上继续说，而我停下了脚步。
"Half price? Are you serious?"
“半价？你是认真的吗？”
"I swear," he said. "And I've never done that for anyone, but I really didn't intend to insult you."
“我发誓，”他说。“而且我从来没为任何人这样做过，但我真的没打算侮辱你。”
"Sayed!" my wife shouted at me. "Where are your values?"
“赛义德！”我的妻子对我大喊。“你的价值观在哪里？”
"Forget values," I told her as I shook the hand of the nice salesman. "The man told you (SPEAKING SLOWLY) half price. Do you understand?" And with tears in his eyes, the salesman said that he would also give us pillows at a big discount.
“忘了价值观，”我告诉她，当我和这位不错的推销员握手时。“男人告诉你（慢速说话）半价。你明白吗？”带着他眼里的泪水，推销员说他也会给我们大折扣的枕头。
December 6, 2012. It's been three weeks of renovation and we've started moving back into our apartment, even though it's still not completely finished. When we got there, two Arab workers from a company that specializes in cleaning renovated houses were toiling in the rooms.
2012年12月6日。翻新已经三周了，我们已经开始搬回我们的公寓，尽管它仍然没有完全完成。当我们到达那里时，来自一家专门清洁翻新房屋的公司的两名阿拉伯工人在房间里辛勤工作。
I felt uncomfortable at having Arabs cleaning my place, but I just nodded and told the contractor who was supervising the renovation that everything was packed and in the car. And that as soon as he gives the go ahead, I will start taking in the suitcases and bags.
让阿拉伯人清洁我的地方让我感到不舒服，但我只是点头，告诉监督翻新的承包商所有东西都已打包并在车里。而且只要他点头，我就会开始搬行李箱和包。
Besides the cleaners, the installer of the banister was also supposed to come. "Two hours of work," the contractor said. "He won't interfere with the cleaners and the cleaners won't interfere with him."
除了清洁工，栏杆的安装工也应该来。“两个小时的工作，”承包商说。“他不会干扰清洁工，清洁工也不会干扰他。”
The banister guy arrived exactly on time. "This is Sayed," the contractor said as he introduced me. The man nodded and smiled.
栏杆的人准时到达。“这是赛义德，”承包商在介绍我时说。那个人点头微笑着。
"Great, Sayed. There might be sparks, so I want you to follow me with a brush and fix up after me."
“太棒了，赛义德。可能会有火花，所以我希望你跟着我拿把刷子，事后修复。”
"No," the contractor said, embarrassed. "He's the owner."
“不，”承包商尴尬地说。“他是房主。”
"Ah," the installer said, and got to work.
“啊，”安装工说，然后开始工作。
"You know," my wife said to me on that sleepless night before the move back, "the house is really charming now. It looks prestigious and comfortable. But still--" she stopped.
“你知道，”搬回前那个失眠的夜晚，我的妻子对我说，“房子现在真的很迷人。它看起来久负盛名和舒适。但仍然——”她停住了。
"Still what?" I asked.
“仍然什么？”我问。
"I don't know," she said, as she always does when she knows. "I'm just thinking about the children again. About what this is doing to them. How they feel. How it will affect their behavior and the way they get along."
“我不知道，”她说，当她知道时她总是这样说。“我只是又在想孩子。关于这对他们有什么影响。他们感觉如何。它将如何影响他们的行为和他们相处的方式。”
"Again the thing with the Jewish neighborhood?" I said.
“又是关于犹太街区的事情？”我说。
"I'm not saying anything," she said. "It's a lovely apartment. Very nice neighbors. But you know."
“我什么都没说，”她说。“这是一个可爱的公寓。很好的邻居。但你知道。”
"No. I absolutely, absolutely do not know," I replied with the jangled nerves of someone who had planned to spend only 20,000 shekels to add a room with a plaster wall, but found himself paying, as of that moment, more than 180,000 shekels.
“不。我绝对，绝对不知道，”我用一个计划只花20,000谢克尔加一个带石膏墙的房间，但发现自己支付，截止那一刻，超过180,000谢克尔的人的神经紧张回答。
"I'm just asking myself," she said, striking a dramatic pose so the words would sink in. "I'm just asking myself if this is our natural place. And even more so for the children."
“我只是问我自己，”她说，摆出一个戏剧性的姿势，以便这些词沉进去。“我只是问我自己这是不是我们的自然地方。而且对于孩子来说更是如此。”
"It is natural," I said. "It's 100% natural."
“它是自然的，”我说。“它是100%自然的。”
The banister guy came up to me smiling. "I hope you'll excuse me," he said. "I just, I never imagined that you live here. You know what I mean, Sayed."
栏杆的人笑着向我走来。“我希望你能原谅我，”他说。“我只是，我从没想过你住在这里。你知道我的意思，赛义德。”
"Sure," I said. "Sure, forget it." And I really meant that, because it didn't hurt me in the least that he thought I was an Arab laborer. At least it didn't hurt me as much as the fact that I had two Arab workers doing their thing in my apartment and I had tried to avoid contact with them until one of them came over and spoke to me in Hebrew.
“当然，”我说。“当然，算了。”我真的那样认为，因为他认为我是阿拉伯劳工一点也不伤害我。至少它没有伤害我，因为我有两名阿拉伯工人在我的公寓里做他们的事情，而我一直试图避免与他们接触，直到他们中的一个走过来用希伯来语和我说话。
"These shoes were thrown out," said the worker, who I estimated was my father's age. "They were in the garbage. Can I have them for the kids?"
“这些鞋子被扔掉了，”工人说，我估计他是和我父亲一样的年龄。“它们在垃圾里。我可以给孩子吗？”
I choked up for an instant, not sure whether to smile, reply in Hebrew, and play the generous Jewish homeowner who takes pity on the wretches, or to answer in Arabic and come across as a maniac Arab who lives among Jews and throws out almost-new Nikes that were brought from the US in the wrong size for the kids. I found myself saying, [ARABIC] "Please, go ahead," in Arabic. And continuing in Arabic, "Of course you can take them. And there are plenty more we had planned to donate if you want to have a look."
我一瞬间噎住了，不确定是该微笑，用希伯来语回复，并扮演那个对可怜人表示同情的慷慨犹太房主，还是用阿拉伯语回答，并以一个生活在犹太人中间，扔掉从美国带来尺寸不对几乎新的耐克的疯狂阿拉伯人出现。我发现自己说，[阿拉伯语] “请，继续，”用阿拉伯语。并继续用阿拉伯语，“当然你可以拿走它们。如果你想看一下，我们还计划捐赠更多。”
"Your Arabic is excellent," the worker said, still speaking in Hebrew.
“你的阿拉伯语很好，”工人说，仍然用希伯来语说话。
"I am an Arab," I declared.
“我是一个阿拉伯人，”我宣布。
The worker did a double take and asked, "And this is your place?"
工人第二次看，并问，“而这是你的地方？”
"Yes," I told him. "We bought it a few years ago. Yes, this is my home."
“是的，”我告诉他。“我们在几年前买的。是的，这是我的家。”
"Wella," he said, still amazed. "I never imagined. [FOREIGN LANGUAGE], thank you."
“Wella，”他说，仍然惊奇。[外语]，谢谢。”
"For what?" I said. I didn't understand what he was thanking me for and I thought for a moment he was teasing me.
“为了什么？”我说。我不明白他在为我感谢什么，我想了一会儿他在取笑我。
"The shoes," he said, holding them up with one hand to show me.
“鞋子，”他说，用一只手举起它们给我看。
"You're welcome," I said. My face burned with shame.
“不客气，”我说。我的脸因为羞耻而灼热。
I talked to my wife late that night after the children were asleep. "What can I do?" I said leaning back a little in my bed. "And what exactly is our natural place? What?"
孩子睡着后，那天深夜我和我的妻子交谈。“我能做什么？”我躺在床上向后靠了一点说。“而什么是我们的自然地方？什么？”
"I don't say it's easy," she said, invoking her social work phrases again. "It can be very hard."
“我不说它很容易，”她说，再次援引她的社会工作短语。“它可能非常困难。”
"So are you telling me that I have to live in an Arab village to feel I'm in a natural place?" I asked. "I'm not allowed city life?"
“所以你在告诉我，我必须住在阿拉伯村庄才能感到我在自然的地方？”我问。“我不被允许城市生活？”
"That's not what I'm saying," she said with a patience that I was quickly losing.
“那不是我在说的，”她说，带着一种我很快失去的耐心。
"Then what are you saying?" I insisted. "I really want to understand. What are my options for being natural? Hmm? To buy a crappy apartment in an Arab neighborhood in Jerusalem? To buy a place in the area that was conquered in 1967?
“那你是在说什么？”我坚持。“我真的想理解。我自然的选择是什么？嗯？在耶路撒冷的阿拉伯街区买一套破旧的公寓？在1967年被征服的地区买一个地方？
What, what is natural? To go back to the village? Back to Tira to the family? To fights between siblings over every meter of land? What is natural?
什么，什么是自然的？回村子？回到提拉去找家人？为每一米土地与兄弟姐妹争吵？什么是自然的？
And what can I do in order to safeguard the children? You tell me that, please! What is right and what is wrong? And I will do it!"
而我为了保护孩子能做什么？请你告诉我！什么是对的，什么是错的？而我会做它！”
"I say you should go to sleep now," she said, rubbing cream into her hands and yawning. "You look tired."
“我说你应该现在去睡觉，”她说，把霜擦在手上打着哈欠。“你看上去很累。”
"Yes," I said. "Goodnight." And I knew I would not sleep soundly. Or wake up naturally.
“是的，”我说。“晚安。”我知道我不会睡得安稳。或自然地醒来。
Actor Ramsey Faragallah, reading excerpts from newspaper columns first published in Haaretz , written by Sayed Kashua. Kashua's latest novel-- it's been translated into English-- is called Second Person Singular .
演员拉姆齐·法拉加拉，阅读首次发表在《国土报》（Haaretz）上的报纸专栏摘录，由赛义德·卡什亚撰写。卡什亚的最新小说——它已被翻译成英语——被称为《第二人称单数》（Second Person Singular）。
[MUSIC - "HOME" BY G. LOVE]
[音乐 - G. Love的《家》（Home）]
Our program was produced today by Miki Meek and myself, with Alex Blumberg, Ben Calhoun, Sarah Koenig, Jonathan Menjivar, Lisa Pollak, Brian Reed, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder with production help from Phia Bennin.
我们的节目今天由米基·米克（Miki Meek）和我自己制作，还有亚历克斯·布卢姆伯格（Alex Blumberg）、本·卡尔霍恩（Ben Calhoun）、莎拉·柯尼格（Sarah Koenig）、乔纳森·门吉瓦尔（Jonathan Menjivar）、丽莎·波拉克（Lisa Pollak）、布莱恩·里德（Brian Reed）、罗宾·塞米恩（Robyn Semien）、艾丽莎·希普（Alissa Shipp）和南希·厄普代克（Nancy Updike）。我们的高级制片人是朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder），制作帮助来自菲亚·本宁（Phia Bennin）。
Seth Lind's our operations director. Emily Condon's our production manager. Elise Ferguson's our administrative assistant. Music help from Damien Graef and Rob Geddes. Research by Michelle Harris.
塞斯·林德（Seth Lind）是我们的运营总监。艾米丽·康登（Emily Condon）是我们的制作经理。埃莉斯·弗格森（Elise Ferguson）是我们的行政助理。来自达米安·格拉夫（Damien Graef）和罗伯·格德斯（Rob Geddes）的音乐帮助。研究由米歇尔·哈里斯（Michelle Harris）完成。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
WBEZ management oversight for our show by our boss, Mr. Torey Malatia, who has-- this is no joke at all-- after all these years resigned from WBEZ this week. That is the truth. I will miss him very badly. Our program would not exist without him.
WBEZ对我们节目的管理监督来自我们的老板，托里·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）先生，他已经——这不是玩笑——在这么多年后本周辞去了WBEZ的职位。那是事实。我会非常想念他。没有他，我们的节目就不会存在。
And should we even do this? Yeah, we have to do this. We can't stop doing this. OK.
而我们甚至应该做这个吗？是的，我们必须做这个。我们不能停止做这个。好的。
Torey, of course, is moving on to other things. Though what does he got planned for this weekend?
托里，当然，正在转向其他事情。尽管他这周末打算做什么？
I'm gonna go commit a crime, make me some money, and then go get me a dope sack.
我打算去犯个罪，赚点钱，然后去买袋毒品。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life .
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI. Public Radio International.
PRI。国际公共广播电台。